the world of Sufism is very diverse
while the core of the tradition is
basically kept intact one very prominent
aspect of tasawof which is the Arabic
word for Sufism is that it exists in
many different local variants and
flavors
this is of course especially true for
its aesthetic expression such as poetry
for example sufis have always taken
inspiration from local forms of music
and poetry in different languages to
express the deepest mystical experiences
we've already talked about some of the
most famous of the Arabic Sufi poets
such as Abu Hassan
Arabi but arguably the most
important and famous in the whole
category of Arabic Sufi poetry is the
Egyptian Sufi Mystic IBN faded whose
masterful verses were revolutionary in
the genre and which in some ways have
never really been paralleled in their
incredibly beautiful expressions of
mystical love and unity
[Music]
[Applause]
while the great and controversial IBN
Arabi who is a revered poet himself can
probably be said to be the most
influential and famous Sufi
metaphysician and theorist in Islamic
history his contemporary IBN faded is
more renowned in the realm of poetry in
particular his ways of expressing the
experiences of Islamic mysticism and the
Sufi way in Arabic became paradigmatic
in later periods and his poems are still
popular today especially in his native
Egypt where they are often sung both
during formal Sufi Gatherings and in
more public popular events
was born in the year 1181 in Cairo Egypt
the name IBN faded means literally son
of the women's Advocate referring to his
father's legal profession but in later
periods he would also be referred to as
Sultan
the Sultan of lovers due to his highest
status as a Sufi Mystic his family was
rather well off and young Oma received a
proper education including in religious
Sciences he studied and followed the
Shafi School of Islamic law and seems to
have become an expert on Hadith the
stories and traditions of the Prophet
Muhammad for basically all of his life
he would remain associated with the
cultural Elites of Cairo as he gradually
became a very respected and renowned
poet who would participate in Gatherings
where poetry would be recited and shared
he also seems to have earned his living
teaching poetry and Hadith
clearly and confirmed by reports he also
at a young age became involved with
Sufism the mystical tradition of Islam
and basically all of his poetry fall
within the Sufi Tradition now the
details of his life are a bit hard to
get at with certainty the earliest
biographical accounts we have of him are
actually from people who were his
students basically so people who knew
him and from these accounts which are
actually very rudimentary there is just
sort of a summary of his life basically
nonetheless it becomes clear that during
his own Lifetime and very shortly
afterwards he was primarily famous as a
poet right he was famous as a very
renowned and very respected poet in
Egypt and not necessarily for being some
kind of Sufi master or Sufi Saint which
would be his reputation later on these
early biographies do confirm that he was
involved with mysticism or Sufism in his
life but that does not seem to have in
the main source for his fame or at least
these biographies do not go into any
sort of detail about his life as a Sufi
it's really only with another
biographical or really a hagiographical
account by his grandson Ali that we get
any details about this stuff
this account well somewhat authoritative
due to having access to family members
who knew the poet should be read
cautiously with a grain of salt since it
clearly has the aim of highlighting the
saintly nature of his grandfather
because after his death IBN faded would
become increasingly known as not just a
great poet but as an accomplished Mystic
and even a saint who had reached the
heights of mystical insight and reading
his actual poetry this isn't to be fair
all that hard to believe
like we said he was born and lived in
most of his life in Cairo but it also
seems that he spent a significant amount
of time of his life in Mecca stories
tell about how as a young man he would
accompany his father to his work as a
woman's advocate but that he would often
instead Retreat to the hills outside the
city to wander and contemplate in other
words he already had a clear spiritual
drive as a youngster
in one such legendary story it is said
that encountered a Sufi Saint while
wandering the hills outside Cairo this
saint told him that he should go to
Mecca to find Enlightenment when IBN
faded commented that Mecca is indeed
very far away the saint suddenly says
it's right there and as IBN father turns
around he sees Mecca right in front of
them a Fantastical tale to be sure but
it does corroborate the idea that IBN
faded went to Mecca at some point
perhaps for as long as 15 years here he
seems to have studied and learned quite
a bit including poetry Hadith and
probably also Sufism because he then
returned to Cairo 15 years later as an
accomplished scholar and poet
and as we said earlier he would spend
the rest of his career teaching poetry
and Hadith in the prestigious mosque the
greatest seat of learning in Cairo and
really at least today in the entire
Sunni Muslim World in other words unlike
many of his Sufi peers who were often
more associated with the poor IBN faded
was very much a part of the cultural
Elite of the city
at the same time though he seems to have
stayed away from political power as such
there are no poems in his diwan
dedicated to political leaders something
that was very common for an accomplished
poet at this time
it thus seems that he followed the
relatively common Sufi principle of
disassociating directly with royalty and
the political Elite to focus on
renunciation and the spiritual path
and that path would indeed be very
important to IBN and father and his life
while his Fame during his lifetime
surely stemmed primarily from his poetry
he seems to have been deeply involved
with mysticism and shortly after his
death people started talking about him
as an accomplished and enlightened
Mystic who had verify the truth of
reality indeed the famous Sufi said
an early follower of the school of IBN
Arabi who also commented on ebnet
falet's greatest work which we will
return to soon said this about the poet
quote
after his vicissitudes in the valleys
and peaks of love and after his evolving
stages among the lofty mountains of
proximity to God he was acquainted with
the splendors of the beauty of this
exalted reality to the most perfect
degree beyond the veils of the robe of
his pride
so he devoted himself to spending the
rest of his life and the next in
stringing the necklace of unique and
guarded pearls in order to clarify the
requirements of the mystical station
and other biographies such as the
aforementioned debaja by his grandson
Ali also attest to the great mystical
fervor of our friend Omar he is
portrayed as an inspired Mystic prone to
bouts of ecstasy where he would
experience a uniting with God and the
Oneness of existence after which he
would compose his poetry in the state of
ecstatic inspiration
now for those of you unfamiliar with
Sufism this is often referred to as
Islamic mysticism it's a certain path
and tendency within Islam which is
heavily ethical and focused on traveling
on these spiritual path to intimacy with
God
it involves a process of turning away
from your nephs or ego or independent
self until is completely annihilated
what is known as fanaa or literally
annihilation in many Sufi circles these
highest stages of that path are
described as a union with God a
realization that the underlying essence
of reality is Oneness and that all that
truly exists is God and reading even
faded's poetry it becomes clear that he
certainly holds to this kind of monistic
view of reality to reach this experience
the sufis adopted practices like zikr
remembrance where names of God or the
Islamic proclamation of Faith were
chanted for long periods of time often
also in a group setting
this practice of wicked has the purpose
of remembering God and forgetting
everything else including your own self
which will hopefully eventually lead to
a unitary experience IBN faded would
have participated in such common Sufi
practices and refers to them frequently
in his poetry quote
Imam
foreign
I pray and so chant when I recite in
memory of her and I Delight in the
prayer Niche while she is my Imam
and on pilgrimage in a pure State I cry
labeka in her name and I see restraint
to be the breaking of my fast
at the same time when talking about
Sufism we should be clear about the fact
that these sufis were devout Muslims
while practices like the good are unique
to sufis basically all sufis also
perform the regular observances of the
Islamic religion praying five times a
day fasting going on pilgrimage to Mecca
Etc they followed Islamic law and were
often indeed especially strict in their
observance of Islamic law
IBN faded was no different and he often
talks about the fact that even when a
Sufi has reached this state of union he
still has to perform all his duties and
rituals as a Muslim this is very
important to remember but Sufi he
certainly was and participated in the
vibrant Sufi environment of 13th century
Egypt
another form of the larger category of
vicar or remembrance is another common
Sufi practice called Sama which
literally means listening or audition
this is a practice that involves
listening to recited poetry or music as
a spiritual observance
poetry would be recited often with the
accompaniment of musical instruments and
sometimes even dance which would help
the Sufi practitioner reach a higher
spiritual State even to the experience
of ecstasy or wajid
the power of music to move the human
soul was not lost on these Muslims and
Sama was and still is a very powerful
spiritual technique while not accepted
by all sufis Sama has been a popular
practice across history it's been made
famous by its more elaborate examples
such as the whirling dervishes of the
meblovy order
IBN faded seems to have been especially
fond of sama there are many stories of
how he would participate in such musical
assemblies and fall into ecstatic States
as a result in one if not farted
spontaneously enters a state of watched
as he simply hears the singing of some
people walking by him in the marketplace
quote a group of guards passed by IBN
faded while they were beating clappers
and singing
upon hearing these verses shouted out
and danced in the marketplace
this attracted a large crowd of people
many of whom fell to the ground in
ecstasy as the guards continued to sing
similarly another account by the
Theologian Abdel Rafa al-qusi states
that a musical Sama session wasn't
complete unless IBN faded attended quote
it is related that if an audition were
held in Cairo or fustot and the Sheikh
sharafadin IBN faded did not attend
there would not be delightful
so it happened that someone invited the
Sheikh and held an audition for him but
the Sheikh was dispirited and so the
occasion was Ill at ease because the
Sheikh was
so the host was pained but the eloquent
singer said to him give me tendinars and
I'll Delight the Sheikh for you
the host replied fine so the singer
asked God's help and recited then he
recites in poetry then the Sheikh had
been farted arose and went into ecstasy
and with that a splendid moment passed
overall
ebnet Father's Love For Sama was no
secret to anyone indeed and even in his
own poetry he expresses this love for
the practice in what is in my opinion
one of the most beautiful sections from
his Masterwork called the Italian kubra
which we'll return to later he explores
the theme of sama and music through a
metaphor of a baby being soothed by the
singing of lullabies a section so
profoundly beautiful that I have to
quota them for in the beautiful
translation by the late Emil hamarain
quote
when the infant moans from the tight
swaddling wrap and restlessly yearns for
relief from distress he is soothed by
lullabies and lays aside the burden that
covered him he listens silently to one
who soothes him
the sweet speech makes him forget his
bitter State and remember a secret
Whisper of ancient ages
his State makes clear the conditions of
samah and confirms the dance to be free
from error
for when he burns with desire from
lullabies anxious to fly to his first
abodes he is calm by his rocking cradle
as the hands of the nurse gently swayed
I have found in gripping Rapture when
she's recalled in the chanter's tones in
the singer's Tunes what a suffering man
feels when he gives up his soul when
messengers of death come to take him one
finding pain and being driven asunder is
like one pained in Rapture yearning for
friends
the soul pity the body where it first
appeared and my spirit rose to its high
Beginnings my spirit soared past the
gate opening to beyond my union where
there is no veil of communion
the singing of the musicians is
represented by the nurse who sings
lullabies to the child
she rocks him in her arms representing
the dance of the Sufi that often
accompanies such music all of which
reminds the soul of its Origins and
unity with God and helps him or her
return to that state of Oneness it's
incredible stuff
and his poetry itself seems to have come
from such ecstatic States
indeed biographies tell of how he would
enter a can of trans become completely
unraptured by divine inspiration for
hours or even days sometimes and when he
returned to his senses he would
spontaneously compose his poems quote
the Sheikh in most of his moments of
inspiration was always perplexed eyes
fixed hearing no one who spoke not even
seeing them sometimes he will be
standing sometimes sitting sometimes he
would lie down on his side and sometimes
he would throw himself down on his back
wrapped in a shroud like a dead man
10 consecutive days more or less would
pass while he was in this state neither
eating drinking speaking or moving
then he would regain Consciousness and
come to and his first words would be a
dictation of what God had enlightened
him with of the old nazma saluk
so what are these poems that he's so
famous for inspired by a Divine ecstasy
or written by a master of language
regardless of which of these is true
it's clear that IBN faded wrote some
amazing verses now the diwan of that is
the collection of his poetry where his
full body of work is relatively small
compared to some of his other some of
his peers such as for example or should
study what is there is incredibly
impressive and once we dive deeper into
his poetry and those poems that are
there shorter of a number as they may be
we quickly realize why he is considered
one of the most
influential and and greatest in history
The Poetry of is arguably all concerned
with the Sufi path and longing for God
it's a poetry of remembrance of vicar
that Central aspect and practice of
Sufism to remember the Divine and
express that ineffable love that pulls
the Mystic towards the essential core of
his reality which is God
but these Sufi themes are often clothed
in the common language of the Arabic
poetic tradition which functions as a
metaphors for this Mystic Quest the
theme of Love is one of the most
recurring in all of his works this is
both metaphorical and direct the
language of lover and beloved and the
passionate longing of the lover to come
closer to and Unite with his beloved is
a theme that he explores in many of his
verses it isn't for no reason that he is
known as the sultan and Asher clean the
Sultan of lovers while all of his work
is revered he is arguably most famous
for two poems in particular
one of which is known as alhamria or the
wine ode in this shorter poem he uses
the imagery of wine and intoxication to
express the Divine love that
extinguishes the self and leads to an
annihilation of that self the wine
represents love that all-encompassing
love that overwhelms the soul and
intoxication or drunkenness is the
ecstatic mystical state that results
from that love
foreign
in memory of the Beloved we drank a wine
we were drunk with it before creation of
the Vine
the poem Delights in the transformative
power of this wine the presence of the
divine within the universe and how this
Divine is recalled and remembered
through thicker to reach Oneness quotes
foreign
but if it is recalled among the tribe
the worthy ones are drunk by mourn
without shame or sin from the depths of
the jar AS it arose though truly nothing
remained save a name
it truly is a beautiful poem full of
incredible imagery and imaginative
metaphors the wine ode has been read and
commented on by sufis and literatures
alike and remains a classic to this day
but arguably his greatest achievement
and the second of the two poems he's
most famous for is an absolutely
breathtaking poem known as ataya El
Cobra basically the great ode rhyming in
the letter tar also known as nasma suluk
the poem of the Sufi way
this is often considered the longest
mystical poem in the Arabic language
with a whopping
761 verses
but it isn't just famous for its length
but also for being one of the most
profound expressions of the mystical
path and divine Oneness ever put into
words the poem is a kind of Epic Journey
as we follow the author from humble
beginnings as a passionate lover of God
eventually reaching stations of unity
with the Beloved followed by
breathtaking visions of the essential
Oneness underlying reality coupled with
advice on the spiritual path and Islamic
practice along the way
this poem became very popular in Sufi
circles shortly after its composition
and has been commented on by some of the
great Sufi figures in history
one of these commentators
another follower of the school of IBN
Arabi wrote this about the poem quote
no one has ever produced the likes of it
in any age or Epoch its expression by
Nature will never again be permitted as
long as night turns today and it is
impossible to describe it by explanation
or characterize it by illusion very high
praise indeed but understandable the
poem is clearly written by someone who
has a Mastery of the Arabic language and
its poetic tradition being able to
employ its vast well of meanings word
plays and symbolism as well as argue
with someone who has clearly had
first-hand experiences of these kinds of
mystical States this combination allows
him to conjure some truly remarkable
passages that put into words what
ultimately cannot be put into words but
he seems to do that better than most as
al-qaisari seems to agree he manages to
encapsulate so many aspects of Islam and
Sufism as it was practiced at the time
from the regular observances of Islamic
law to things like vikr and Sama and
even certain Sufi metaphysical ideas
such as the Nur muhammadiya the
muhammadan light and other related ideas
all of it in this one poem The Scholar
Michael cell says quote the poem of the
Sufi way is a microcosm of Islamic
Tradition at the time of IBN al-faded
the poem begins like many other love
poems with a scene once again evoking
the wine and the longing for the Beloved
that the poet experiences quotes
the palm of my eye handed me loves heady
wine to drink and my glass was a face of
one revealing loveliness
drunk by my glands I caused my
companions to suppose that drinking
their wine had brought my heart Joy but
by the dark pupils of the eyes I did
without my drinking Bowl
from the eyes find qualities not cool
wine okay my intoxication
the first section of the poem expresses
how the poet seeks Union with his
beloved which is God
interestingly God as the Beloved is
referred to most often in the poem with
the pronoun her
as the metaphor of lover and beloved
runs through the whole narrative
however the mood suddenly shifts around
85 verses in as the Beloved suddenly
responds by totally rejecting the poet
he has boasted about its great love and
the great devotions he has performed
piously withstanding pains and even
delighting in them to reach a state of
intimacy but none of this is true
he is full of Pride and really only
loves himself not her quote you are
Love's Ally All right but for its sake
not mine
as my proof you have saved an attribute
of yours for you never loved me so long
as you were not lost in me and you will
never be lost without my form in you
revealed
it's after this dis that the true
transformation takes place
the poet is a shame then realizes his
mistake now he has been brought low in
complete submission he realizes that the
only way to truly reach his Love's
desire is to annihilate his own will
completely to where nothing remains in
the heart at all but the Beloved and it
is only then that he finally reaches
Union quote
foreign
to her I prayed my prayers at Abraham
station and I witnessed in them her
prayers to me
both of us one worshiper bowing to his
reality in Union in every prostration
the poem expresses this experience of
unity and Oneness throughout in
different ways and in different stages
here the poet has become completely
annihilated become entirely intoxicated
and effaced in the reality of God where
there is no trace of Multiplicity or
self at all this is the date of fanaa or
Annihilation as we talked about earlier
but after fanaa comes another stage
which is known as Baka subsistence in
God remaining in God
at this point the Mystic returns from
intoxication to a second kind of
sobriety he comes back to himself into
the world of Multiplicity but now he
sees it in a completely different way
he no longer views himself as an
independent entity but only as the
self-disclosure of God his self is no
longer limited and finite but the self
with a capital s that reality which
encompasses everything in Oneness
in this station which is called that of
Allah
the all-comprehensive unity the heart of
the Mystic his true self also becomes
identified with the all-comprehensive
principle that is the source of all
things in the universe would later refer
to as insan al-kaman the complete human
being but which have been father himself
refers to as the Nur the light or the
Nur muhammadiya perhaps the the light of
Muhammad representing a kind of logos
principle in the end it was within
himself that the Beloved or God was to
be found all along and he now
experiences that presence of God at all
levels of reality
quotes
I sought her for myself she was there
all along
how strange that I had concealed her
from me
calling to myself from me to guide me by
my voice to that part of me lost in my
search
me begging me to raise the screen by
lifting up the veil for I was my only
means to me
I was gazing into the mirror of my
beauty to see the Perfection of my being
in my contemplation of my face
and mouthing my name I listened and
leaned toward me looking to one who
could make me hear mention of me in my
voice
in other words from the state of being
completely effaced in God being nothing
and experiencing nothing but that
absolute Oneness the Mystic returns to
the world and instead experiences the
presence of God everywhere
there is only God and both within
himself and in the world outside he sees
nothing but God as the Quran says quote
whichever way you turn where is the face
of God
IBN faded says quote passion annihilated
the attributes here between us that had
never abided there so they passed away
and I found what I had Cast Away
emerging to me returning from me in
abundance
the whole world is the manifestation of
the names and attributes of God and to
the Mystic who has reached union he or
she can see and experience nothing but
God in the outer and inner worlds the
beauty of the universe is nothing but
the beauty of God a Divine display and
disclosure
every sense experience becomes a kind of
vicar or recollection where God has
witnessed and tasted quote
The North Wind guides her memory to my
spirit whenever it comes from her by
Night rising up at dawn and my ear is
pleased when her memory is roused at
noon by Dusky dubs on branches wobbling
and gently cooing
my eye is blessed when a lightning flash
relays to it from her thought of her in
the evening and I taste and touch her
memory in vessels of wine when at night
they come round to me
thus my heart reveals to me her memory
within but what the sense Messengers
delivered from without
it is some truly remarkable expressions
of unitive experience and a beautiful
way of putting into words some of the
core teachings of Sufism
love is a theme that runs through the
whole poem as you can see it is love
that drives the lover towards his
beloved it is love that leads him to
forsake and forget his own self to
become annihilated in the self of
reality
and it is that love which permeates the
heart of the enlightened Mystic as he
experiences that love as the nature of
all things all the world is made of love
and that love which is realized is
extended to all of the world
since one sees nothing but God one loves
everything
an infinite love of Nature and the
creatures of the world which is
identical to a love of the essential
Oneness underlying it all
in some ways it is this love with all
that it entails that lies at the core of
reality
in the famous Hadith kudzi God says or
Muhammad says that God says I was a
hidden treasure and I love to be known
so I created the world that I might be
known
God thus creates the world out of that
love to be known
and literally the word is used to it so
it is from The Root Hub which means love
God loves to be nons who creates the
world to be known and to be loved love
is thus the essential force behind all
of creation
and that love is reciprocal
just as God loves his creation and the
manifestation of that hidden treasure so
God's creation loves him the purpose of
Creation in the Hadith was that God
should be known and to love is to know
intimately so in a way when we love God
and know him the whole purpose of
creation is fulfilled
the tension or reciprocal love between
the absolutes and his own manifestation
to himself
this becomes relevant in the text as the
poet has reached that state of unity and
Oneness thus seeing reality for what it
is in an absolutely breathtaking section
from the poem The Poet in this state
becomes identified with every lover
seeking his beloved each instance of
which is a representation of that
essential loving movement of the
universe in my opinion this has to be
one of the most profound and beautiful
expressions of Oneness mysticism or
simply devotion ever composed by a human
being asym says quote every Adam of me
witnessing her loveliness with every
glance of every shining eye
all my subtle words adoring her with
every tongue profused with praise
smelling her sweet scent with every
fiber of every nose breathing in the
rising air
every bit of me hearing her word with
the ear of all hoping to hear
every part of me kissing her veil with
every mouth and each touch and kiss
had she unrolled my body she would have
seen every essence with every heart
holding every love
huge props to the late scholar Emil
hamrain for this beautiful translation
into English as well there's of course a
lot more to go through when it comes to
the Italian Cobra it is a very long poem
after all but these are some of the core
themes and movements of this poem and as
I hope you can see and agree with it is
an incredible piece of work one that
would ensure ebnel father's reputation
as probably the most renowned and famous
Sufi poet to ever write in the Arabic
language
passed away in the year 1235 at a meager
54 years old he was buried at the
clarafa cemetery at the foot of Mount
mukhatam where he used to go on his
Retreats as a youngster his Shrine still
stands there today and has throughout
history been a popular pilgrimage site
and a place where Sufi Gatherings took
place
as we said earlier shortly after his
death his Works were deeply studied by
some significant groups of sufis in
particular the Sufi master and
philosopher saturated the stepson and
primary disciple successor to mohedin
IBN Arabi had a great love for evnel
Father's poetry
while they never met in person at punawi
and his own students who resided in
Konya in Turkey traveled to Egypt and
stayed there for a number of years
during which they primarily studied the
poems of ibnon faded and the Tai El
kubra in particular
sadridine and kunawi would hold lectures
and sessions where he gave his
interpretation and commentary on the
taiah to him this poem expressed in
verse really well the teachings of his
master IBN Arabi which became later
known as
the unity or the Oneness of being it is
as a result of these lectures that the
first commentaries on the poem started
to emerge written by the immediate
students of kunawi himself the very
first of these commentaries written by
said al-farhani has become a famous work
in its own right and it has been said
that the introduction to that commentary
the mukhadima is itself one of the best
and clearest expressions of the school
of ever written other commentaries
followed most of them by the students of
konawi or by later direct followers of
that school which is often referred to
as the akbari school after IBN Arabic
and much later on
all wrote Famous commentaries that
became influential for this reason ABN
faded has been strongly connected with
the school of IBN Arabi in particular
since it was members from this school
that were the primary commentators on
his works even I have relied to some
degree on akbari interpretations in my
comments on the Tai El cobra in this
episode but there is no evidence that
I've ever met even Arabi or that he
adheres to his particular metaphysical
ideas
in other words konawi and his students
probably projected the teachings of the
Great Master on turb not fariba
but after all when we read The Poetry
itself you can clearly understand why
while he might not follow the particular
details of akbari metaphysics it's clear
that he holds a world view that is very
similar in its emphasis on a kind of
monistic Theology and his ideas of
Oneness all ideas that were very popular
in Sufi circles in general in any case
the akbarians found in IBN faded's
poetry Expressions very similar to the
ideas of and we can certainly argue that
they were both trying to explain the
same thing in slightly different ways
still we should remember that the
father's poetry stands on its own and it
should be read to some degree on its own
premises so to say a poetry that strikes
us as not only incredibly technically
proficient and and impressive in terms
of the Arabic language and how he uses
that in the poetic traditions and all
that but also has a beautiful and
profound expression of some of the core
teachings and aspects of Sufism
the Sultan of lovers is still remembered
today across the Middle East
particularly in Egypt and its
surrounding regions he is remembered as
the most popular and influential Sufi
poet in history as well as an
accomplished Gnostic and Sufi Saint
responsible for many miracles his Shrine
in Cairo is still visited by many people
today and an annual maulid is celebrated
to commemorate his life his Sufi
tradition and love for zikr and Sama has
lived on at his Shrine indeed the famous
18th century Syrian Sufi Abdullah
al-nablusi which we mentioned earlier is
one of the main akbari commentators on
Advent father's Works describes in his
travelogue how he visited Egypt and the
shrine of ibnel father in particular
where he took part in an intense and
ecstatic session of samah or musical
audition while such Gatherings aren't as
common anymore it shows that the legacy
of the great poet has lived on
throughout history his poems are still
song at maulid celebrations in Egypt as
well as on music recordings and in other
circumstances the great literary
tradition of Sufism cannot be talked
about without mentioning IBN father
whose poem of the Sufi way stands as one
of the crowning achievements of mystical
literature
I'll see you next time
[Music]